Nicolas Dupont Aignant se présente comme
le candidat des petits mais pas comme un
petit candidat il est avec nous ce soir
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous le
patriotisme les références Gaulistes le
rejet de l'Europe actuelle et de l'euro
et bien tout cela vous anime depuis
quelques semaines que l'égalité parfaite
des temps de parole vous permet enfin
d'être exposé dans les médias vous aurez
des choses à dire sur ce sujet je crois
d'ailleurs vous contestez certaines
règles non pas du CSA mais mais des
médias eux-mêmes c'est bien cela Nicolas
duponignon sur le plan économique les
experts ont des doutes j'ai envie de
dire ou parfois même des certitudes ils
disent à propos du programme de Marine
Le Pen la sortie de l'euro qu'il nous
mènerait sans doute à la ruine sur ce
planl vous répondrez dans un instant aux
questions d'Hervé Hasquin de l'Agence
France Presse et puis perinarna de
Public Sénat nous rejoindra pour la
3oème partie de cette émission d'abord
Nicolas dupignant l'après Toulouse et
Montauban aljazira donc ne diffusera pas
la la vidéo du tueur qu'elle a reçu par
par voie postale c'est c'est évidemment
un
soulagement c'est un soulagement bah
c'est évident c'était tellement
monstrueux ça aurait été un second crime
après le premier HM est-ce honteux comme
le dit Nicolas Sarkozi de dénoncer le
travail ou peut-être simplement de
s'interroger sur le travail des forces
de l'ordre non mais là et de
surveillance le président de la
République comme c'est dommage parce que
le Président de la République a été
digne pendant cette période et à nouveau
retombe dans les excès
euh moi j'ai félicité les forces de
l'ordre leur
sangfroid leur capacité à
arrêter le meurtrier pour autant on a
quand même le droit de s'interroger dans
une démocratie sur le fonctionnement
d'un système de renseignement et quand
madame jolie par exemple dit qu'il y a
pas un pays démocratique où les deux
responsables de la police irait pas Vané
devant les
médias comme en France elle a raison je
veux dire une chose est de conforter les
forces de l'ordre dans l'opération et
elles ont été remarquables une autre
chose est de s'interroger quand même sur
l'incapacité de surveillance d'un homme
qui avait accumulé un stock d'armes
incroyable qui était interdit de vol
pour aller aux États-Unis et qui avait
été en Afghanistan et qui était suivi
par ailleurs par la DC d'ailleurs moi je
crois qu'il ne faut pas mettre de
l'huile sur le feu je crois qu'il faut
un juste
équilibre le problème de fond c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les forces de police de
gendarmerie les forces judiciaires les
douanes n'ont pas les moyens nécessaire
à l'exercice de leur mission donc on
demande à des gens qui sont je l'ai dit
plusieurs fois des héros de faire un
travail dont ils n'ont pas les moyens
une question de moyens pour vous c'est
une question de c'est évident il suffit
de voir les policiers les gendarmes ce
sont des gens admiraable qui simplement
sont démunis c'est la grande misère de
l'État diriez-vous que ce manque de
moyens conduit à des failles je n'en
sais rien mais je demande qu'on ait le
droit de s'interroger quelles sont les
questions que vous vous vous posez les
question POS c'est comment on a suivi
est-ce qu'on a les moyens de suivre
est-ce que ce service a tous les moyens
nécessaire est-ce qu'il n'est pas
distrait par d'autres occupations est-ce
queah j'en sais rien il faut lui
demander est-ce que euh en tout cas moi
je sais qu'il faut rétablir le contrôle
aux frontières pour lutter contre le
trafic d'armes on demande à la police et
à la gendarmerie avec 12000 agents de
moins 12000 en 5 ans de faire un travail
alors même qu'on a ouvert toutes les
frontières mais on voit le résultat
insécurité galopante trafic d'armes
homicide en permanence dans beaucoup de
villes de France ça peut plus durer
alors que le Président de la République
ne mélange pas tout la nation a été
unanime derrière ses policiers et ses
gendarmes maintenant on a a quand même
le droit de s'interroger sur des
dysfonctionnements Bernard Squarcini le
patron de la DCRI a Démé aujourd'hui que
Mohamed Mara fut un indicateur est-ce
que vous avez pu avoir ce genre
d'interrogation vous je n'y vais même
pas penser mais voyez je suis naïf
euh mais je je trouve d'ailleurs
surprenant que les ministres le ministre
d'intérieur ne s'exprime pas j'estime
que les fonctionnaires sont là pour
obéir au gouvernement et non pas pour
parler à la place des ministres et
j'étais très étoné de voirant que claud
Guan c'était peut-être beaucoup eximer
sur le non pas du
tout non pas du tout jamais reproché JIS
reproché à Cl son boulot
jamais en revanche j'estime que ce n'est
pas à des policiers d'aller sur les
plateaux de télévision le chef de l'État
en tout cas veut accélérer les
procédures d'expulsion des extrémiste et
il veut interdire d'entrer
également ceux qui contestent les
valeurs de la République tout ça bien
sûr va dans le bon sens là on pour
retrouver le consensus non mais on peut
enfoncer les portes ouvertes comme ça
toute la journée et pourquoi il l'a pas
fait avant ça fait 5 ans que ça se fait
pas ça fait 5 ans qu'il y a des prêches
de haine dans certaines mosquées c'est
curieux donc soit ça n'a pas été fait
pendant 5 ans et c'est quand même grave
et il devrait plutôt rendre des comptes
soit il dit ce qui se fait et c'est son
boulot c'est normal donc vous savez je
crois que les Français vont être lassés
de ces gesticulations présidentielles h
très lassés parce que on attend du
président de la République du sérieux il
a été remarquable pendant la période du
drame et là à nouveau l'esprit
politicien reprend le tessu ça ne
trompera personne moi je crois que les
Français attendent de la cohérence donc
que le Président de la République nous
explique comment il va faire pour mettre
davantage de policiers de gendarmes
plutôt que de donner de l'argent à des
banque en Grèce ça sera beaucoup plus
utile et moi je propose et je suis
candidat pour ça l' nexcu pas l'autre
hein bah écoutez jusqu'à maintenant
c'était d de l'argent pour les banque en
Grèce et pas pour les policiers donc moi
je suis candidat parce que je veux qu'on
sorte de cette politique alors on va av
vous abordez aussi tout de suite la
question européenne on va y revenir un
peu plus tard dans dans le spectacle le
showbe on a l'habitude ça fait 5 ans que
ça du le showbiz le showbiz sur une tuie
aussi atroce non le showbiz après après
je parle pas j'ai été précis j'ai des
paroles précises le président a été
remarquable de dignité pendant la
période et là on recommence des annonces
c'est honteux de se poser des questions
enfin on est en démocratie ah bah on est
depuis 5 ans dans un système de showbiz
politique oui des annonces jamais suivi
des faits ça'appelle ça le showbise des
annonces jamais suivi des faits je dis
qu'on a voté ici dans cette maison au
Cénat et à l'Assemblée nationale et j'ai
voté des lois plus de 10 lois ces lois
ne sont pas appliquées alors avant d'en
inventer de nouvelles j'aimerais qu'on
puisse appliquer les lois qui existent
c'est lois de la République un mot sur
les valeurs de la République et les
valeurs tout courts que vous défendez
Nicolas dupoignant comment est-ce que
vous réagissez quand vous apprenez que
le père du tueur donc c'est algérien qui
vit dans son pays envisage de porter
plainte contre la France pour la mort de
son fils bien j'ai honte voilà je suis
outré comme tous les Français voilà que
dire de plus vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure des prêches enflammées dans
certaines mosquées françaises il y a un
instant mais vous jugez au dieu en même
temps le rapprochement qui a été fait
par Marine Le Pen entre les thèmes de
l'Immigration et du terrorisme néanmoins
vous estimez euh j'ai trouvé absolument
au dieu qu'elle puisse dire les Mohamed
et cetera qui arrivent en ce moment sont
de futur tueur j'ai trouvé ça ça m'a
coupé le souffle et je me suis dit qu'en
fait elle était comme son père euh j'ai
trouvé ça au dieux parce que ne
confondons pas vraiment ne jetons pas
l'anathème sur une population et je
voudrais dire à Marine Le Pen qu'il y a
des Français des jeunes Français qui
sont de confessions musulmanes qui sont
arrivés sur eux sans doute les bateaux
dont elle faisait état et qui sont morts
en Afghanistan sous le drapeau français
il y a des Français des jeunes Français
de confessions musulmanes qui se sont
engagés dans l'armée française il y en a
beaucoup dans notre armée et donc on n
pas le droit quand on est un responsable
politique de souffler sur les bresses
comme ça ça me choque je suis un
républicain Gauliste je n'accepte pas ça
néanmoins ce qui n'interdit pas en
revanche oui de vouloir éétablir un état
de vouloir éétablir des frontières de
vouloir contrôler l'immigration mais de
grâce qu'on ne mélange pas tout
contrôler l'immigration parce que vous
estimez qu'il y a trop d'étrangers en
France j'estime qu'il y a un devoir
d'intégration
important que dans une société qui a
perdu un million d'emplois en 10 ans il
est totalement irresponsable de faire
entrer 200000 étrangers par an légaux et
je ne parle pas des illégaux que les
entreprises françaises certaines
entreprises font venir alors même qu' y
a chiffre à 100000 par an comme Nicolas
Sarkozi
d'isure en tout cas c'est le bon sens
c'est de dire quoi sous Lionel Jospin il
devait avoir à peu près
100000 ça fonctionnait je pense qu'on
est passé d'ailleurs sous Nicolas
Sarkozi à 200000 c'est assez stupéfiant
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
lois ne sont pas appliquées ça veut dire
qu'on n pas traité le problème de fond
le problème de fond qui est l'attrait
par des chefs entreprises ce que
j'appellerais pas malhonnête mais malsin
qui font venir des main d'œuvrees bon
marché et puis il y a un problème qui
aura la solution mais qui est
fondamentale et dont on ne parle pas
dans cette campagne c'est le
développement de l'Afrique c'est la
stabilisation du Maghreb et quand je
propose un europrotectionnisme eurom
Méditerrané j'ai une vraie vision de ce
qu'il faut faire pour l'Afrique et le
Maghreb et si on ne traite pas ce
dossier africain on aura des problèmes
migratoires considérables dans la
campagne vous avez beaucoup de choses à
dire hein Nicolas dupontignan vous êtes
aussi contesté on va le voir dans un
instant notamment sur vos propositions
économiques le retour on va en parler
avec Hervé dans un instant mais la
notion de frontière est revenue dans la
campagne à travers également Nicolas
Sarkozi ou HRY gu qui en parle son sa
plume he est-ce que vous estimez comme
HRY Guen qu'il y a un problème avec les
immigrés certains immigrés car on
n'arrive pas à assimiler tous ceux qui
sont là il y a pas de problème avec les
immigrés il y a un problème avec la ié
française qui ne crée plus d'emploi qui
a une école qui est devenue laxiste et
qui a un état faible et donc la question
c'est pas de jeter de l'huile sur le feu
à l'égard des immigrés parce que leurs
enfants sont français et pour la plupart
sont des bons patriotes problme le
problème est économique et social et moi
j'en ai assez de voir Monsieur gu écrire
des choses très justes mais servir un
président de la République pas du tout
servir un président de la République qui
fait l'inverse
c'est ça le problème de fond parce que
sinon ce serait merveilleux je prends un
exemple le président de la République
parle de l'Europe passoir mais c'est lui
Nicolas Sarkozi qui a signé le traité de
Lisbonne qui a abandonné le droit de
veto de la France dans les négociations
commerciales donc moi je suis candidat
pas pour commenter les autres on les a
assez vu je suis candidat pardonnez-moi
pour dire aux Français qu'on peut agir
différemment et pour proposer un projet
qui tient la route alors je vais pas
commenter éternellement les actions des
autres puisque de toute façon les
Français ont jugé ils savent que ça
tient pas la route simplement ils sont
perdus parce que il voit bien que
Hollande ça serait pas mieux ça pourrait
même être pire il voit bien que le Front
national c'est l'excès et justement moi
je suis candidat parce que je veux
proposer un patriotisme républicain avec
des mesures économiques radicalement
différentes pour relancer la machine on
y arrive on y arrive on y arrive mais
d'abord encore une question Nicolas du
poignon vous rejetez le Parti socialiste
vous rejetez l'UMP vous employez
d'ailleurs la même expression que Marine
Le le système UMPS vous l'avez déjà
utilisé ça fait 30 ans attendez oh là
c'est le même langage mais c'est mais
est-ce que j'ai on a le droit de parler
librement dans notre pays s tout de
suite qu'on nous parle de Marine Le
Pen qu'on en parle parce que vous êtes
vousouvezouvez sur des points essentiel
attendez ça c'est la vieille lune pour
toute personne qui pense différemment
que l'UMPS ouis qui nous gouverne depuis
30 ans je vous ferai remarquer 15 ans
socialistes 15 ans TR législatures
socialistes tr 3 UMP je voudrais vous
faire marquer qu'ils ont laissé la
France dans un état catastrophique les
deux là catastrophique et ces deux
partis qui ont échoué en tout qui ont un
bilan accablant volent monopoliser la
vie politique et se serent du Front
national comme repoussoir et bien
justement ça va gêner que moi j'arrive
et que je vais dire aux Français vous
pouvez vous passer deux sans tomber dans
le piège du Front national d'accord
alors vous acceptez quand même que je
dise qu'il y a des similitude pour le
moins entre votre projet et celui de
Mar pourquoi vous ne dites pas qu'il y a
des similitudes entre mon projet et
celui de Monsieur montebour pourquoi
vous ne dites pas qu'il y a des
similitudes entre mon projet et celui de
Monsieur Nikonov d'attaque qui a qui
vous propose la sortie de l'EUR qui
vient la gauche néanmoins quand je
regarde non mais non mais c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est toujours
vis-àis de Madame Le Pen jamais vis par
que je vais vous répondre qui propose
parmi les candidats l candidats à la
présidentielle la sortie de l'euro sinon
vous et Marine Le alors on voit ça on en
parle on en parle plus dans le paysage
politique et économique certes mais dans
la présidentielle si Nicolas dupignant
on voit ça avec Marie Bro avant
d'accueillir Hervé de lap normal que je
vous avez raison
j'argumente et si Nicolas dupontignan
était légal masculin de Marine Le Pen a
y regarder d'un peu plus près les
similitudes sont nombreuses les deux
proposent l'abandon de l'euro le le
rétablissement des frontières ils
veulent tous les deux revenir à ce
qu'ils appellent l'Europe des nations et
les deux veulent un certain
protectionnisme économique deux
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
pour un seul et même programme abandon
de l'euro retour au Franc instauration
de droit de douane pour relocaliser
l'activité en France stricte séparation
des banques de dépôts et des banques de
crédit priorité absolue au PME mais les
analogies vont bien au-delà des mesures
économiques le peen du pontignant même
combat pour l'abrogation de la loi
adopie le rétablissement des frontières
la création massive de places de prison
la réduction drastique du N d'immigrants
sur l'immigration les deux vont dans la
même direction mais Marine Lepin va tout
de même plus loin que Nicolas d
pooignignnant sur le regroupement
familial Marine Le Pen veut la
suppression du regroupement familial
monsieur dupoignan veut sa suspension
pendant 5 ans Marine Le Pen est la seule
à prenner la suppression du droit du sol
et également la suppression de la
binationalité donc elle va un petit peu
plus loin tout serait une question
d'histoire de passer d'héritage celui de
Nicolas Dupont etignan souverainiste
dans la lignée des pass pas et ce gain
est plus facile à porter que celui de la
candidate frontiste elle doit composer
dans son parti avec une frange
véritablement radical extrémiste
antiystème
antirépublicaine ce n'est pas le cas de
Nicolas dupontaignan donc là-dessus il
est quand même un peu plus à l'aise à
l'aise le président de Debout la
République l'est suffisamment pour
envisager Marine Le Pen à Matignon si
lui accéder à
l'Élysée voilà elle ou elle ou un autre
hein vous allez nous parler non mais je
veux répondre parce que ça ça fait
partie de la ritournelleord pour faire
peur aux Français et pour leur faire
croire qu'on peut pas être patriote et
républicain donc c'est
facile mais j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit le
jour où Marine Le Pen abandonnera cette
idéologie xénophobe extrémiste et
qu'elle reviendra dans une ligne
républicaine je pourrais comme
Montebourg ou Mélenchon la mettre comme
premier ministre c'est pas du tout la
même chose et j'insiste là-dessus parce
que justement ça fait 20 ans qu'on nous
a mis dans le piège du Front National et
moi je dis qu'on peut être patriote mais
qu'on peut rassembler tous les Français
je n'ai jamais fait la moindre
différence entre un français de quelque
origine qu' soit d'où qu'il viennent et
je n'accepte pas je n'accepte pas cette
volonté toujours d'extrémiser les gens
qui sont patriotes ça a été fait à une
époque avec chevinement qui a été
ridiculisé par Canal plus dans les
guignoles on le faisait passer pour un
fasciste alors Chevénement était un
républicain je suis un Gauliste
républicain je n'ai rien à voir avec le
modèle de société Mad Le Pen je ne veux
pas dérembourser l'IVG je ne veux pas
rétablir la peine de mort j'ai un autre
modèle de société et je veux que ce soit
dit Hervé askin bonsoir bonsoir Michel
question donc sur le projet économique
de Nicolas dupoignon résumé d'ailleurs
dans ce livre le printemps français un
programme très détaillé mois après mois
qui montre bien qu'il est beaucoup plus
sérieux que celui du frond national
bonsoir Nicolas d ponteignan alors j'ai
une question à vous poser on va se
situer dans un exercice on va faire un
exercice de politique fiction et
peut-être même d'économie fiction
honneur c'est un honneur pour moi en
tout cas euh nous allons nous projeter
dans l'avenir imaginez que vous décollez
dans les sondages vous quittez la zone
disons de relégation pour être qualifié
vers un second tour sont les Français
qui décideront ce sont les Français qui
décideront personne nent les sondages
pas les sondages non non plus ni des
journalistes mais vous êtes au second
tour et vous êtes élu bon dans ces
circonstances élu quelle est votre
première décision économique sortir de
l'euro oui bien sûr euh enfin non il y
en a peut-être une autre avant la
première décision économique euh c'est
de mettre en place un protectionnisme
minimum lorsque les euh pays émergents
euh trichent avec toutes les règles du
jeu ce qui est le cas aujourd'hi oui
mais enfin le problème des pays
émergents c'est c'est un vrai problème
mais mais l'économie française n'est pas
tourné vers les pays émergents le nombre
de chômeurs que j'ai rencontré
d'entreprise délocalisé parce que la
décision était prise d'aller produire en
Chine à 50 € par mois avec des esclaves
des nouveaux esclaves pour accumuler les
profits ça c'était très concret et je
vous renvoie sur le million d'emplois
industriel perdu tout n'est pas lié
c'est évident tout n'est pas lié vous
avez raison au pays émergents mais si on
ne me dit pas stop à l'échange déloyal
d'ailleurs je me réjouis parce qu'
aujourd'hui même à gauche au Parti
socialiste même l'UMP commence à
réaliser que j'avais raison on parle de
juste échange maintenant oui bah c'est
une façon élégante sauf qu'il faut
passer à l'acte je vais vous donner un
exemple et puis Onra à l'euro un exemple
très concret la Chine vient d'interdire
l'importation de bouteille d'vian et de
Volvic sous prétexte que c'est dangereux
pour la santé l'Union européenne vient
de signer un accord avec la Corée du Sud
c'est même le responsable de Peugeot qui
s'en nomme mouvais qui autorise
l'importation de voitures de Corée du
Sud en Europe mais qui interdit en Corée
du Sud je veux dire que c'est le le
démantèlement total et inégal des
barrières douanières il faut mettre fin
à cela si on veut éviter qu'on perde
encore 500000 emplois industriels dans
le prochain mais mais vous savez bien 60
% 60 % du commerce extérieur français
c'est vers l'Union européenne vous avez
raison et c'est pourquoi et c'est
pourquoi il faut agir aussi sur l'euro
d'ailleurs je vais revenir sur l'euro il
y a pas que l'euro et le protectionisme
il faut baisser l'impôt sur les sociétés
qui réinvestissent en France il faut
remettre les banques françaises au
service de l'économie réelle il y a pas
du tout que des Affaires extérieures
nous avons aussi nos propres défauts
soyons clair mais l'euro est un point
clé fondamental j'étais hier dans dans
charante un chef d'entreprise vient me
voir il me dit monsieur vous avez raison
dans mes exportations j'ai créé une
entreprise aux États-Unis j'en ai une
autre en France je délocalise aux
États-Unis parce que je suis en zone
dollar l'euro c'est 20 à 30 % de
surévaluation monétaire tous les gains
de productivité que je fais ils sont
bouffés par la monnaie je n'arrive plus
à produire en zone euro bon on va
revenir à
l'euro une question sur sur la situation
de relative de la France et de
l'Allemagne les deux pays appartiennent
à la même zone agissent dans des
conditions économiques et politiques
similaires appartiennent à la même Union
européenne sont les deux moteurs de
l'Union européenne aujourd'hui et
pourtant il y en a un qui fait 150
millions 150 milliards pardon
d'excédents commerciaux et un autre la
France malheureusement 70 milliards
déficit commercial et vousz alors les
barrières oui mais les barrières les
barrières douanières elles servent à
quoi et bien je vais vous dire une chose
très claire pas de barrière douinière à
l'intérieur de la zone euro je veux pas
mettre des barrières douinières je vous
ai parlé d'un protectionnisme quand il y
avait des concurrences déloyales quand
on est concurrence attendez quand on est
en concurrence loyale je ne mets pas de
protectionnisme il en est pas question
je veux pas une France fermée en
revanche avec l'Allemagne c'est évident
150 milliards d'excédents d'un côté 70
milliards de découverts de déficit de
l'autre ça veut bien dire que la
situation mérite une action très rapide
ça veut dire surtout qu'à armes égales
on a pas les beons résult ex-moi ça veut
dire que les Français ne sont pas comme
les Allemands oui ça c'est sûr ça veut
dire aussi qu'il a un pays en suicide
démographique en suicide démographique
qui va avoir dans 20 ans un problème
majeur et un pays en France qui a 40 %
de taux de chômage dans les quartiers
qui a une croissance démographique donc
c'est déjà pas le même pays deuxièmement
c'est un pays qui a pas la même
structure industrielle troisièmement
c'est un pays qui n'a pas le même effort
de défense et les mêmes dépenses
publiques qurièmement c'est un pays qui
ne veut pas agir pareil qui a pas la
même tradition économique alors il y a
deux solutions soit on dit comme le fait
la classe politique depuis 10 ans il
faut qu'on soit comme les Allemands en
parole c'est très bien sauf que ça
aboutit à la ruine de la France soit on
comprend que la monnaie et vous êtes
suffisamment érudit dans ce domaine que
la monnaie c'est un élément qui doit
être adapté à la compétitivité dans la
vie il faut pas une monnaie trop chère
et il faut pas une monnaie trop faible
la France est morte dans les années 30
avec l'aval qui a fait une politique du
Francfort qui est arrivé exang en 36
alors que l'Angleterre avait compris
qu'une monnaie c'est un
moyen la monnaie compr vous on sort de
l'euroors d'abord le fr revient on le
dévalue de combien attendez 2 secondes
non mais on prend l'hypothèse où vous
êtes élu on sort de le r vous
dévaluez si je peux vous répondre
d'abord je regret de vous annoncer que
même si je ne suis pas élu
l'euro sera probablement fini avant la
fin du prochain quinquena pour une
raison très Simp certains disent
aujourd'hui qu'on est sorti de la crise
bien sûr mais bien sûr j'en prends le
Paris icions attendez non mais je
voudrais quand même répondre parce qu'il
y a la situation de l'Espagne qui est en
train d'arriver là grandv dans quelques
jours que personne ne voit et l'Espagne
est dans une situation on a l'impression
vous vous frottez les mains hein je me
frotte pas les mains je vois la réalité
que la petite classe parisienne niit
parce qu'elle veut pas voir on est dans
le dogme en Allemagne j'ai des amis
allemands professeur d'économie il y a
un vrai débat sur l'eurau et on écoute
est-ce qu'on peut à votre
propositionv et je ne dévalue pas je
transforme 1 € en 1 € franc d'accord
ensuite les lois du marché fonctionnent
plusieurs banques ont étudié ont
modélisé ns Mura et une autre qu'est-ce
qui se passe l'euroarque se réévaluera
de 20 à 30 % conformément à la
compétitivité allemande ce qui évitera
les excédents excessifs de l'Allemagne
deuxièmement l'euro lire et dragme se
dévalueront fortement l'euro PZ au
regard de leur compétitivité et il est
estimé que l'euro franc dévaluera
légèrement entre 10 et 15 % légèrement
oui et c'est une chance c'est une
chance explosion ça veut dire une
explosion du cû du pétrole ah mais bien
sûr mais je vais vous
répondre d'autres
arguments et les 1700 € 1700 milliards
d'euros de dette de la France qu'il
faudra rembourser en euro deutchmk comme
vous l'avez dit alors ça c'est la fable
je vais vous dire
pourquoi pour deux raisons
d'abord je veux vous répondre sur la
valeur de la monnaie pourquoi tous les
pays du monde sauf la zone euro alignée
sur l'Allemagne font une politique de
monnaie pas trop cher pourquoi le
font-ils si c'est si dramatique que ça
pourquoi la Chine sousévalue sa monnaie
de 50 % pourquoi Monsieur qui tient tant
à l'euro pour nous lui a laissé filer la
livre de 20 % pourquoi la Suède s'en
sort avec 4 % de croissance cette année
pourquoi le slot polonais a été lissé de
20 % pourquoi les États-Unis de Monsieur
Obama tiennent à ne pas avoir un dollar
trop élevé il faudra que vous
m'expliquez ça c'est la première chose
c'est curieux il y a que vous qui savez
et tous les autres sont des Ames non
mais peut-être que l'Europe l'Europe
pourraitid réiser la valeur de sa
monnaie là dans une position commune ça
l'Allemagne ne le veut pas donc il y a
bien un moment il fa en tirer les
conséquences euh si l'Europe voulait
changer l'euro ça se saurait ça fait 10
ans qu'on le demande les socialistes
l'UMP ils échou ils sont à genoux et ils
perdent les emplois donc moi je veux
qu'on agisse et vous en avez parlé avec
nos voisins européens de vos projets ils
sont d'accord bien sûr j'ai été en Grèce
en Espagne en Irlande il y a beaucoup de
peuples qui ont compris que l'euro était
fin peup oui enfin peut-êtreou mais
peut-être que vous savez en démocratie
les peupes compte plus que les que les
dirigeants on a vu ça au moment
révolution les gouvernement
d'aujourd'hui les gouvernement d'jour
d'aujourd'hui ils sont temporaires parce
que quand vous condamnez un pays comme
l'Espagne à 50 % de taux de chômage pour
sa jeunesse quand dans nos quartiers en
France il y a 40 % de chômage quand en
Grèce c'est le chaos est-ce qu'on a le
droit de traiter l'Europe comme ça donc
moi je propose pas de tout casser je
propose une monnaie commune beaucoup
d'économistes ont proposé l'euro franc
l'euro marque avec une monnaie de
réserve et je propose chers monsieurs
que cette monnaie permette enfin de
produire sur le continent europé et en
France je propose ensuite pour la dette
je vais vous répondre sur la dette parce
que c'est un point très important je
propose enfin qu'on rétablisse la
capacité de la Banque centrale à
financer à 0 % les grands
investissements publics et je propose la
monétisation qui est chiffré dans mon
programme sur mon site internet il a été
modélisé chiffré NDA 2012 vous verrez
nous proposons de monétiser 100
milliards d'euros par an à 0 %. comme
l'Angleterre le fait en ce moment
100liard tout à fait et bien très bien
voyez vous pourrez dire que je ne suis
pas unomextrme
droite c'est tellement facile tellement
facileèon propose quelque chose parce
que cette petite classe politique qui a
mené la France à la ruine estime qu'il
faut
continuer pour résumer est-ce que vous
voulez renationaliser la France non non
parce qu'il faut l'initiative privée je
finis ma phrase làdessus d'accord en
monétisant 100 milliards par an à 0
% on réduit la charge de la dette
l'intérêt de la dette qu'on paye chaque
année en 2017 nous payerons plus que 30
milliards au lieu de 50 ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que les 20 milliards
d'économie sur les intérêts d'emprunt
parce que je pense qu'il est préférable
de moins payer sur les marchés
financiers et avec cet
argent de financer mes mesures pour
l'économie productive baisse de moitié
de l'impôt sur les sociétés pour les
Bénéfic réinvestis en France ça veut
dire rupture des accords européens c'est
ce qui se fait aux États-Unis ça veut
dire sortie de l'Union européenne terme
non renégociation aux États-Unis
monsieur quand un chef d'entreprise
investit il a un impôt qui diminue quand
il investit sur le sol américain
pourquoi on peut pas le faire en France
deuxième mesure recrutement pour les TPE
exonération de toute charge sociale pour
un chômeur de longue durée car il vaut
mieux payer un manque de charge sociale
que de payer des allocations chômage de
longue durée 5 milliards d'euros pour un
emploi par TPE pendant 5 ans 5 milliards
d'euros de non recette pour la baisse de
l' 5 milliards pour l'aide pour les
chômeurs de longue durée c'est 10
milliards d'euros au lieu de les payer
aux banques j'insuffle de la création de
richesse dans notre pays c'est ça
l'enjeu ce que vous ne comprenez pas
c'est qu'on peut pas continuer dans un
pays où celui qui produit en France est
défavorisé par rapport à celui qui
délocalise mais mais cette France
repliée sur elle même pas replié si elle
si avec des droits des droits des droits
de douinees aux frontières avec avec sa
Monet qui retrouve et ce est replié
pardonnez-moi le cinéma français est-ce
qu'il est
replié je pense qu'il est très ouvert
sur le monde mais il est en concurrence
à l'extérieur PL quota de quota de
consommation avance sur recette oui et
bien le cinéma français en France marche
bien donc vous acceptez pour les acteurs
de cinéma et les metteurs en scène ce
que vous refusez pour les
ouvriers la Malaisie sais pas si on pe
faire le parallèle entre les œuvres de
l'esprit et puis la non parce que c'est
vrai que la douleur d'ouv jeté comme un
chien c'est beaucoup moins important que
de savoir si le petit Paris va pouvoir
faire du cinéma pas ce que je dis pas ce
que je dis non pas du tout moi je vous
le dis pourquoi la Malaisie pourquoi
l'Argentine pourquoi le Brésil pourquoi
le Japon pourquoi l'Allemagne vous
parlez tant de l'Allemagne Volkswagen je
me suis renseigné j'ai vérifié quelque
chose Volkswagen le land de Bass sax est
actionnaire à 20 % et il y a une loi
particulière qui interdit aux
actionnaires privés sur le marché
d'avoir plus de 20 % du droit de vote
c'est-à-dire que les 75 % d'actionnaires
privés ne peuvent pas décider pour
Volkswagen donc il faut arrêter avec
cette fausse idée du repli la
mondialisation c'est un combat et dans
le combat on a le droit de se protéger
mais cette France la dernière pasé alors
cette France qui va oui enfin dans un
univers moins
concurrentiel comme les autres comme la
Chine ser plus compétitive mais est-ce
qu'elle sera plus compétitive bien sûr
parce que quand vous êtes pas en
concurrence avec une monnaie de 20 %
trop cher 20 % trop cher quand vous
faites pas face au dumping quand vous
avez des banques qui aide à la création
de richesse et quand les charges
baissent sur les PME au lieu de payer
des intérêts d'emprunt pour une
oligarchie financière qui s'en met plein
les poches et qui a échoué c'est quand
même pas la même chose pour les
entrepreneurs alors justement donc c'est
pas la même politique qui s exuse les
poches vous allez pouvoir les évoquer
dans un instant avec perine Tarnaud qui
va nous rejoindre mercici Hervé perine
arrive donc juste après cette enquête de
Tam tranui sur vous elle a eu beaucoup
de peine sachez-le à faire parler
d'autres souverainistes même si vous
n'aimez pas le mot de vous-même la
souveré du pop c'est un beau mot oui d
tranui Charles pascois Philippe
Devillier Jean-Pierre Chevenement Lionel
LUCAS ou encore Jacques mard la galaxie
souverainiste englobe des personnalité
politique de tout bord et elles ont
toutes un point commun aucune ne veut ou
ne peut parler de Nicolas du pontaignnan
une histoire de rancœur ou encore de
mépris à l'égard du petit candidat qui a
créé son propre parti à Debout la
République on préfère prudemment parler
de routes qui se sont séparées
aujourd'hui l'UMP a trahi un certain
nombre d'idéos goolistes qui étaient
résiduel suite à à la fusion du RPR avec
démocratie libérale euh aujourd'hui ces
idéos sont défendues par Debout la
République et quand deux chemins
politiques se séparent forcément il y a
une forme de concurrence des divergences
de points de vue il y en a eu dans le
parcours de Nicolas du pontignan le
président de Debout la République a
côtoyé à peu près toute la planète
politique de droite à ses débuts il
rejoint le RPR et se rapproche de
Philippe ségin avant de s'inscrire au
RPF de Charles pascoy et de Philippe
Devillier en 2002 malgré son soutien à
Jean-Pierre Chevénement il rejoint l'UMP
et forme le club gouliste Debout la
République un mouvement qui devient
finalement un parti en opposition à la
décision de Nicola Sarkozi de contourner
le nom au référendum de 2005 sur le
traité constitutionnel européen cette
déception fondatrice c'est vraiment en
fait le viol du vote de 2005 et le choix
de passer par le Congrès et non par un
référendum pour valider le traité de
Lisbonne c'est à partir de ce moment-là
en fait que la déception est devenue
définitive et que Nicolas dupontignan a
décidé de partir dans un parcours
totalement indépendant des grands partis
alors un fidèle Nicolas dupontignan un
brin versatile peut-être ou déçu devant
l'éternel par la machine des grands
partis lui qui se dit ni de gauche ni de
droite se retrouve aujourd'hui isolé sur
les chiquiers politiques et seul face au
Français sous l'ombre tutellaaire du
général de Gaulle dont il revendique
l'héritage même s'il ne l'a pas beaucoup
oup connu qu'on puisse
dire recnaiss parce que on veut bonsoir
madame c'est très cohérent moi j'ai
essayé je viens de la droite du RPR je
suis Gauliste j'ai adoré Philippe segin
j'ai combattu mastrich avec lui j'ai
jamais changé d'opinion j'ai combattu
Amsterdam j'ai même démissionné de mes
fonctions RPR j'ai rejoint Philippe dev
Villier ils sont après arrêtés je
continue c'est très cohérent c'est très
cohérent cohérent indépendant mais seul
mais seul mais je suis pas seul j'ai la
chance d'avoir un parti politique qui a
de plus en plus de monde en île-de-fance
on est plus de 11000 adhérents en
île-de-fance on me disait 0 % dernière
régionale on est quand même passé devant
le MoDem besann qui était les
coqueluches des
médias sol ça veut dire quoi quand vous
regardez les chiffres des sondages par
exemple mais ça me fait hurler de rire
moi je vais vous dire je suis quand même
élu maire dans ma ville depuis premier
ENF mieux élu de France premier tour ou
premier tour 80 % mieux élu de France je
me souviens quand je me suis présenté
les sondage me disait 3 jours lo
attendezz voir 3 jours avant l'élection
les sondages disaient il sera jamais élu
élu au premier tour législative je suis
le seul à avoir gagné dans la
dissolution une circonscription de
gauche à droite on me disait jamais élu
au régional 0 % on a dépassé le modem
vous savez les sondages sont faits pour
enfermer les Français espz mais j'espère
convaincre les Français qu'on peut bâtir
une autre politique et dépasser au moins
mais vous pouvez être méprisante vis
desol on pas on n pas méprisant on vous
demande votre objectif je vais vous dire
euh quand on parle des avec mépris de
certains scores 2 % des voix c'est un
million de Français moi je crache pas
sur un million de Français euh
quand la vie politique regardez les
écologistes ils ont eu des haut débat
ils ont quand même influencé beaucoup le
Parti socialiste moi je crois que la
France parce que c'est ça la vraie
question je crois que la classe
politique française est au bout du
rouleau je pense que très vite
euh la situation va s'aggraver et que la
vraie question pour les Français c'est
de savoir si il veulent continuer avec
cela ou s'ils veulent trouver la
solution qui va permettre avec des
efforts ça ça viendra pas du ça tomberas
pas du ciel sortir de la crise et c'est
ce que je vais proposer à la France
voilà et puis on verra ce que diront les
Français et c'est un long combat qui
commence mais aucun mépris de notre part
évidment mais pas de chez vous mais
parfois toujours est-il que c'est
certainement un des deux grands partis
français qui va remporter cette élection
présidentielle soit le parti socialiste
soit l'UMP en tout cas c'est ce que
semble indiquer pour l'instant les
sondages on est à peine à un mois du
premier
tour la question peut-être laissz les
Français juges sur la droite Nicolas
Sarkozi a réuni toute la famille toute
la droite autour de de lui du centre
enfin partie du centre de la France du I
la France du non vous vous faites plus
du tout partie de cette famille là à
droite aujourd'hui non puisque cette
famille a trahi la France oh mais je le
pense donc je va pas vous dire le
contraire doncour doncour vous nppz
pastique il mène une politique qui est
en train de précipiter notre pays dans
un chaos économique et social j'en pèse
mes mots et je sais la gravité de ce que
je dis donc psump dans le même sac mais
je finis ma phrase la gravité de ce que
je dis parce que moi je vous dis une
chose madame si on continue cette
politique de l'eurocher du librechange
des loyales on a déjà perdu 1 million
d'emplois industriel en 10 ans il suffit
qu'on en perde de à 300000 encore et on
est parti pour ça veut dire je finis ma
phrase ça veut dire que la sécurité
sociale et les retraites ne seront plus
financées à partir de fin 2012 ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que le prochain
Président de la République oui madame
qu'il soit de gauche du PS du PS
totalement inepte sans aucun programme
ou monsieur Sarkozi seront face à une
colère sociale et un chaos politique
sans précédent et il est de mon devoir
d'homme politique depuis 15 ans députés
je les ai vu vivre je les ai vu voter
n'importe quoi sans prendre en compte
l'urgence de la situation et bien il est
mon devoir d'homme politique de dire aux
Français il faut changer rapidement de
cap si on veut pas aller sur le récif
alors on l' dit on l'a dit on l'a dit
vous l'avez répété vous l'avez répété
donc ça veut dire que pour le deuxème
tour vous n'appeller à voter pas qu'
sera au 2è tour n'en tirez pas des
conséquen vous pas au 2è tour si Nicolas
S est au deè tour estce que vous
vous voulez pas prendre position non
parce que y a un prier tour est-ce que
vous excluez de voter Nicolas SAR oui ou
non je ne vous répondrai pas il y a un
premier tour non parce qu'il y a un
premier tour d'accord bien sûr on le
sait mais ah ben on le sait mais on veut
le syème aujourd'hui qui veut zapper le
premier tour je n'ai pas d'opposition
personnelle aux hommes d'accord que ce
soit Nicolas Sarkozi ou François
Hollande soyons clair un Nicolas Sarkozi
ou un François Hollande qui dirait
demain matin sort de l'euro on se
protège on mène une autre politique on
dénonce les traités de Bruxelles je suis
capable d'accepter je suis pas borné se
produira pas on a compris vous n'en
savez rien bon petite question
d'actualité Maurice Lévy à la tête de
publiciste va toucher un bonus de 16
million d'euros c'est un montant qui
vous choque honte à lui honte à lui il
l'a pas mérité non non un bonus sur les
résultats finaners à lui honte à lui une
réribution différée je vais vous dire il
devrait avoir honte ce monsieur ne sait
pas dans quel pays il vit je dis honte à
lui il a signé récemment une pétition
pour dire que les riches devaient payer
plus d'IMP sans toute et bien écoutez
moi je dis que quelqu'un qui vit en
France d'aujourd'hui où 2 millions
d'enfants 2 millions d'enfants sont
élevés dans notre pays sous le seuil de
pauvreté un pays qui jette ses ouvriers
ses agriculteurs un agriculteur par jour
se suicide dans notre pays et est-ce que
ce monsieur que je ne connais pas je lui
en veux pas personne ement se rend
compte de ce qu'il est en train de faire
au détriment de la libre entreprise
parce que moi je crois que l'avenir du
pays viendra de la libre entreprise de
la création de richesse est-ce qu'il se
rend compte un instant de ce qu'il est
en train de faire autre je crois pas
autre question dans l'affaire sin il ne
le ferait pas si c'est un homme sensé et
je crois que c'est un homme intelligent
donc il devrait y renoncer et le
partager entre tous les employés de sa
société on verra si entend le message de
la classe politique aujourd'hui dans
l'affire B en cour l'ancien gestionnaire
de de fortune de la famille Patrice est
en prison il y reste est-ce que vous
pensez que derrière mes derrière Eric
vert il y a le financement occulte de la
campagne de sarczi en 2007 moi je ne
suis pas un justicier je suis pas juge
en revanche je demande que la justice
passe et que le Président de la
République éventuellement s'explique
voilà il a le droit de s'expliquer voilà
en tout cas je demande que d'un côté il
y ait pas de justicier moi je suis pas
perd la morale mais en revanche il faut
pas qu' l'OM
et le fait que Monsieur Mestre soit en
prison je ne sais pas si c'est justifié
ou pas il n'est pas condamné il est mis
en examen d'après ce que j'ai compris
c'est simplement que justice passe et il
est clair qu'il faudra un jour que le
Président de la République s'exprime
quand même avant la fin de la campagne
on est rentré dans la campagne
officielle de cette élection
présidentielle ce qui vous permet
normalement de vous exprimer égalité
avec les autres candidats dans les
médias les médias se donne du mal en
principe en principe est-ce que vous
êtes satisfait par cette situation 5
semaines de campagne officielle contre
deux pour les élections je vais vous
dire une chose je suis satisfait qu'en
République pendant 5 semaines sur 260
semaines d'un quinquena il y ait une
égalité de traitement c'est normal euh
quand on envoie la profession de foi
vous savez vous allez recevoir votre
domicile le papier il y a pas un timbre
poste pour les 10 petits candidats et et
10 pages pour ceux qui sont favorisés
par les sondages depuis la fondation de
la République la profession de foi à la
même taille ce que je regrette un peu
parce que c'est un peu mesquin
c'est que tout le monde n'est pas comme
vous c'est qu'il y a certaines chaînes
qui suppriment les émissions politiques
peut-être parce que les règles du jeu
sont non les règles du je sont très
simples vous les faites la plupart le
font c'est 10 émissions ù beaucoup de
chaînes suppriment les émissions
politiques c'est scandaleux et c'est
mauvais pour la démocratie c'est mauvais
pour la légitimité du futur président
deuxième point je regrette une chose
c'est qu'il a pas de débat et que
monieur sarczi et Hollande pareil vous
allez dire j' le veut à tous les deux ne
veulent surtout pas débattre avec
Monsieur Mélenchon avec Madame le P avec
Monsieur Baou avec Monsieur dupontignan
parce qu'en fait comme il raconte
n'importe quoi aux Français et qu'ils
savent très bien qu'ils ne mèneront pas
après 2012 la même politique qu'il
annonc ils ne veulent pas qu'on leur
pose des questions et je trouve ça quand
même très frustrant pour l'opinion que
il y ait pas des débats comme il y a eu
pour la primaire socialiste finalement
pour une élection privée il y a eu plus
de débat que pour une présidentielle
c'est quand même dommage-moi concernant
votre en tout cas merci à vous parce que
vous c'est la seule émission longue
qu'on a et on le fait avec beaucoup de
de
de et d'intérêt vos
arguments mérite d'être entendu à propos
de votre future élection législative
éventuelle si vous n'êtes pas élu
président de la République à hier là
vous êtes brillamment réélu non
seulement à la mairie mais comme député
vous aurez un adversaire de l'UMP en
face de vous oh je je le pense je
l'espère même ça serait cl vousespérrez
un mot pour conclure sur la mise en
examen pour proisme aggravé de Dominique
stros ça vous inspire une réflexion
grandeur et misère du pouvoirin j'en
sais rien il est pas condamné encore une
fois j'ai horreur des justiciers en
politique très biens bien ce sera le mot
de la fin voilà même si vous voulez
régler son compte à la monnaie commune
enfin vous avez bien exposé les choses
j'essaie d'exposer mes convictions je
suis sincère on peut au moins me
reconnaître ça merci à
vousci merci Nicolas dupontignant on a
été heureux de vous recevoir aujourd'hui
à 22h une autre édition de preuve par 3
tout à l'heure et notre invité sera
Jérôme Cahusac qui est chargé du 22h30
chargé du but la
fiscalité auprès de François Hollande
merci et puis la semaine prochaine
Nathalie de lut ouvrière la
recevoirev jean-pierrearin également pas
dans la même émission je vous le
rappelleyez qu'on peut y arriver on y
arrive on y arrive bonsoir et c'est vrai
que les auditeurs sont ravis des
téléspectateurs d'entendre toutes les
voix de la campagne
bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être en notre
compagnie ce soir les trois thèmes de
cette campagne 2012 seront la crise la
crise et enfin la crise la politique ce
n'est pas la guerre civile a donc dit
Xavier Bertrand parler de ce printemps
du
jasmin sa victoire si elle est vérifiée
demain est-ce qu'elle est surprenante
comment vous jugez son action dans cette
tempête qu'à l'époque on avait tous ri
aujourd'hui on rit moins votre
rendez-vous quotidien avec l'information
c'est du lundi au jeudi à 22h sur
public
les agriculteurs ont toujours voté à
droite d'une campagne et l'autre vous
emmènent dans le morbillan chez Frédéric
et Jean-Michel des éleveurs qui n'ont
pas encore choisi leur candidats notre
expert des sondages nous dira ensuite
vers qui les agriculteurs se tourneront
en 2012 enfin suivez-nous dans les
cortèges d'Europe écologie des vers avec
Christian militant av il se démène pour
que la question du nucléaire ne passe
pas au second
plan
la Bretagne première région agricole
française en 2007 Nicolas Sarkozi et les
autres candidats parlent peu
d'agriculture pourtant dès le premier
tour plus d'un agriculteur sur deux
choisit le candidat UMP depuis les
difficultés se sont accumulé concurrence
internationale volatilité des prix et
autres sécheresses une période de crise
inédite fait douter un monde agricole en
pleine mutation d'une campagne à l'autre
direction l'exploitation de saintdoué en
plein cœur du morbillan c'est parti
chaque matin chaque soir pour Frédéric
c'est le même rituel et ça dure depuis 5
générations aujourd'hui la traite de ces
145 vaches va rapporter 3400 L de lait
vendu à la coopérative voisine oui mais
voilà depuis 2007 les prix font du yoyo
et rendent le quotidien parfois
insupportable on avit pas le choix de de
continuer mais pour vous dire quand vous
levez le matin et vous savez que c'est
pour quasiment rien
gagner problématique aujourd'hui les
prix du lait ont retrouvé des couleurs
et Frédéric un peu de sérénité ce
soir-là Jean-Michel son associé est venu
lui prêter main
forte sa production à lui c'est la dinde
la grande spécialité du morbillant on
les entend chanter comme ça pour nous
c'est un critère important c'est que ça
se passe bien quoi à chacun sa
spécialité et ses problèmes pour élever
ses 1300 d'Inde Jean-Michel chauffe son
hangar à près de 25°grés et sur le gaz
difficile d'économiser c'est un coout
important du de l'élevage en 3 semaines
on a déjà consommé 2 tonnes5 de gaz ça
correspond à peu près à 2000 € 30000 €
cette année et une facture en
augmentation de 20 % depuis 2 ans hausse
des charges baisse des prix de vente des
produits pour lisser leurs revenus les
associés séduits par le Grenel de
l'environnement se lance il y a 3 ans
dans l'énergie solaire 760000 € investis
1200 panneaux installés et la promesse
de revenus durable quand Frédéri avait
lancé C idée là c'était de de d'amener
un notre nouvel revenu sans sans avoir
trop de travail aujourd'hui nous avons
atteint en 10 mois l'objectif de
production annuelle une production
au-delà de leurs espérances mais
toujours pas le moindre centime d'EUR
touché EDF tarde a signé les contrats et
la baisse de 20 % du prix d'achat de
l'électricité verte décidé par le
gouvernement a doucher leurs espoirs ah
non non on était on est catastrophé
quelque part c'est vrai que pour ce qui
est de notre
histoire non on peut pas dire que l'État
a vraiment rempli son rôle tel qu'on
nous l'avait promis au départ chez les
paysans breton la révolution verte est
en marche qu' un cas en attendant il se
verse 1500 € nets par mois pour 70 he de
travail hebdomadaire le prix d'une dure
vie de la beur parfois
récompensé on se retrouve avec Frédéric
et Jean-Michel la traite est terminée ça
va maintenant être l'heure de parler
politique messieurs alors en dem une
grande partie des agriculteurs avaient
choisi de soutenir Nicolas Sarkozi
est-ce que vous aviez voté tous les deux
à ces présidentieles on peut dire que on
a voter pour Monsieur Sarkozi à l'époque
il y avait un certain dynamisme
d'fficher donc on pensait tous queah
l'avenir allait être plus beau que le
passé et puis c'est vrai que la campagne
avait sûement été très dynamique quel
regard aujourd'hui vous portez sur les 5
années passées au pouvoir par Nicolas
Sarkozi beaucoup d'fit d'annonce et et
souvent après peu d'actes et ça dans le
monde agricole on aime pas beaucoup
parce que nous dans le monde agricole on
a une caractéristique c'est la valeur
donnée à la parole la façon dont s'est
passé les 5
ans on se pose vraiment la question si
on sera encore là demain quoi tellement
c'est compliqué qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
demain que l'État prenne comme décision
pour que votre agriculture reste
compétitive et que vous ayez des revenus
honnêtes en Allemagne les énergies
renouvelables se sont développé mais de
manière très très importante alors chez
nous on a dit qu'on allait le faire on
l'a fait et après on a fait un
moratoire donc on fait toujours les
choses à moitié voir au quart et
aujourd'hui on se trompe de route la
campagne présidentielle débute à peine
le premier tour ça sera le 22 avril
prochain 2012 est-ce que vous savez déjà
pour qui vous allez voter j'ai pas envie
de deevoter pour pour la même chose en
tout cas jusqu'ici je la trouve pas très
intéressante
je trouve qu'on ne prend pas
assez d'exemples qui fonctionnent on dit
bah voilà c'est c'est le marché mondial
c'est la crise c'est la bourse c'est
mais de là à nous sortir une vision des
choses c'est pour ça pour le moment
j'attends on a vu dans le reportage que
vous êtes de plus en plus sensibiliser à
l'environnement au développement durable
est-ce que ça voudrait dire que demain
vous pourriez voter écolo bah si on nous
propose d'arrêter de produire je pense
que c'est sûr que ce sera pas possible
de voter écolo et puis toute façon la
décroissance à ses limites parce qu'on
va pas non plus mettre tout le monde au
chômage et je pense que bah on peut
travailler ensemble mais à condition que
bah qu'on nous écoute aussi et qu'on
viennent pas avec une solution toute
faite qui qui nous dit de Ben nous
agriculteurs soi-disant classés
productivistes ben
débarrasser le plancher quoi Jean-Michel
Frédéric merci et puis bonne
continuation à vous
en 2007 plus de la moitié des
agriculteurs français avaient choisi
Nicolas Sarkozi